hello everyone and welcome back to the
Magnus Invitational we are continuing
our coverage with the match and
information versus onigiri before we
check out what happened here and what
happened in the match I would just like
to say that we are continuing with our
Friday arena sun-lee chess so the two
links will be in the description below
if you want to play again two
tournaments first we're gonna have a
warm-up tournament for below 1700
players so the first link will lead you
to that tournament and then for the main
event everyone is of course accepted is
will be the link below that so you can
join either both or if you are rated
above 1700 and then only the latter one
and I don't know when I will be finished
uploading the games from today so it all
depends when I will start streaming and
showcasing your games but I will do it
definitely so that being said do join
the tournament we had a lot of fun last
time so you know hopefully we can do
that again and now getting back to this
game napal with the white pieces opens
with c4 and this is a game - a game one
ended in a draw and this is quite the
game with E 5 by Gary Knight to c3 so
the English opening we have Knight to f6
Knight to f3 and the knight to c6 the
four Knights of the English we have g3
now and d5 now immediately striking in
the center we have captures captures and
Bishop to g2 so all standard stop with
Bishop to c5 and here nipple goes for
Queen to c2 which is a new move in the
position for example the England had
this against the team over job of in the
World Cup I think three times or two
times where were castles was played but
here quintus it is a new move by nepo
saying that okay now if the knight moves
obviously there's some pressure on your
bishop so giri immediately kicks kicks
away the Queen we have Knight B to D
Knight B to D 4 goes after sorry Knight
to e2 b4 goes after the Queen Queen to
a4 and now again Bishop to d7 pushes the
Queen even further back so nipple goes
all the way back to d1 and now Knight
the d4 by giri threatening nice to see
to check to pick up the rook on a1 so
nipple castles and
now Knight captures on f3 with Bishop
captures on f3 and now just knight back
to c6
we have b3 by Napo and Bishop e3 now
offering sorry first Gary castles and
then never was Bishop to e3 offering
here a trade which would give white some
more control of the center and also the
semi open F file so Gary not interested
in that he just goes Knights to d4
instead and offers the b7 pawn here
so Knepper grabs it with Bishop captures
rook to b8 Bishop back to G 2 and now
rook captures and b2 and now there's a
there's some pressure on the e2 pawn so
rook to be won
I never wants the trade of that rook on
the be file and queen to be it by Gary
just protecting the rook with Bishop
captures on d4 relieving some pressure
bishop characters and now Knight to d5
with a with an excellent outpost for the
knight on d5 we bash up the g4 again
Giri goes for that e to pawn also da to
pawn yeah we'll be pressured later on
and now comes nice the e7 with check
this was the idea now that the bishop no
longer guards the c6 where king to a
trade and now Knight to c6 attacking the
Queen and the bishop so eliminating one
of the attackers because this is very
annoying you can't play this because the
Queen hangs and you can play f3
obviously because it's a check to the
king
so Queen to b6 and now Knight character
Sundy for e capture Sun before and now
will be it will be hard enough even in
the future turn to put this pawn so here
at Bishop to f3 by nipple yeah he was
very much enjoy this he would get rid of
his weak weak eat you pawn and his King
sir would be much safer now he would
have some problems with this d3 pawn but
nothing serious
so instead Bishop the h3 by Gary going
after the rook here but now first rook
captures on b2 Queen captures and queen
to c1 trying to get the rook out of
harm's way this way and here if you if
you trade let's say Queen captures here
then you just go Queen the a1 and you
well obviously hope to trade and go
after the a 7-point and
the ship here will make it impossible
for the rook to defend so here is
probably have to move the Queen and then
just then you move the rook and then
you're gonna pick up the pawn to win
back your extra pawn because because as
long as this Bishop is on f3 this is
completely safe there's nothing black
can really do about this so instead we
have looked to be a dry Giri and now
comes the Queen captures on c7 nepo
gives up the exchange here and it's it's
one of the more interesting exchange
sacrifices I've seen in a while here but
should capture screen captures in the
now f6 just getting rid of this weakness
here and the Queen captures on a7 so
here a nipple is up two points by the
giver ease of the exchange however with
this Bishop on FS regarding the e2 pawn
which guards the d3 point and everything
else is nicely guarded the rook is
pretty much helpless against this setup
so Queen to b6 offering a queen trade
but now Queen f7 we have Queen to c5 and
now a King to g2 just getting the King
to a safer Square and now the bishop
also covers the aah square which is is
the queening square so it could be could
be somewhat problematic for Geary
Luke the f8 kicking away the Queen Queen
d7 and now Queen to a3 going after the
pawn here so Quinta eastex defending it
and now f5 preparing effort to open up
the position with h4 by neppo he wants
to play h5 h6 and also open up the Kings
side so h6 and now Queen to c4 we have
king to h7 of course nepo not interested
in grabbing the pawn and then giving up
the a to pawn the a 2 point is the is
the real star of this show even though
it's not doing anything for the moment
we have h5 by Napo and now rook to f6
Bishop the d5 now if if ruk the a6 comes
then the a two point will be protected
twice so Queen the c3 offering a queen
trade and Queen B 5 and here Queen back
to c8 so Russia back to f3 and now Queen
to a6 again offering a queen trade and
going after the pawn here so Queen b3
defending the pawn and now Queen the a5
and here we have a 4
the point started the march forward now
look the Asics going after the pawn and
now of course Queen to f7 now you cannot
grab the pawn if you grab the pawn
you're getting made at Queen captures
here with the check King h8 you're gonna
deliver another check and then just
brush up the e4 check and that's just it
if you go here Bishop here and it's mate
it's unstoppable
so really really really exciting stuff
so rook to d6 instead and now Queen to
e7 putting pressure on the rook we have
looked the d8 controlling the back rank
and now Bishop the c6 just defending the
pawn once again King to h8 and now King
to H do we have worked the c8 going
after the bishop and now Quinta ecigs
just defending and here we have Queen to
a6 giri finally manages to trade Queens
as now if you don't do anything you're
just gonna lose a bishop here so Bishop
to d7 and now we have a queen trade
captures captures and now rook to e8
going after the Bishop rook the c5 is
also possible just defending the f5 pawn
while also keeping an eye on the a5
square however instead of defending he
goes for the counter-attack
rook to e8 he goes after the e2 pawn so
nipple captures and here we have rook
captures and a2
kingi to defending the F DuPont and now
putting the rook behind the passport and
nip of course defends it and now comes
g6 you have to start getting your king
internal game with H captures King g7
and now Bishop to EA to defending so now
the bishop nicely defends that these two
pawns but rook to a3 going after the d3
pawn so you can defend all of them
Bishop to b5 it's more important not
allow not to allow black to have a
passed pawn of his own
so King captures in g6 and now f4
starting to put the pawns and start
bringing your King into the game we have
rook to a 1 and now King f3 we have King
to f6 and now comes g4 we have kink the
e6 and now King to e4
we have ripped the g1 going after the
pawn here but now Bishop the a6
defending would atactic if rook captures
then Bishop ch-check picks up the rook
so look back
a one in here better back to c4 with
check King f6 and nipple just brings the
bishop back Bishop to b5 and here is a
moment where Geary missed missed what
nipple just did nipple just repeated the
exact same position but only now with
the king and f6 instead of an e6 and it
looks irrelevant but it's it's highly
relevant
so here what what you should do is go
back King g6 and either accept that this
is a draw or force white to do something
else instead give everyone for rook to
g1 now going after the pawn but now it's
a bit different because well feel free
to pause the video and try to find why
it's different while I give you a couple
of seconds it's not easy you have to see
if the removes ahead but the three
correct ones of course so for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations as those were not easy
moves to find and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show
it's actually a 5 now giving up this
pawn and now the problem is that the
King is a much further away from the
past pond and then when he was on e 6
because if you're an e6 you just just go
to d6 and you are closer to the pawn
here the problem is you don't really
have a good good reply here if you just
go back pawn comes to a6 and now you've
just given Y 2 2 3 moves a5 a6 so here
you have to capture the g4 pawn but now
comes a six rook to g7 and now the move
you had to find Bishop the c6 and this
is this is how white prevails problem
now is if you don't react for example if
you play something like this then there
should be 7 and if you start pushing it
in white just gives up the bishop and
then brings the Queen into the game so
of course giver could not allow that
he played rook to e7 but now again we
have a look in quarantine at the bishop
just locks at out of the game completely
and now White's plan is is fairly simple
he wants to get the King over here
either grab the rope or force the rook
to trade so Geary starts pushing h5 but
now King characters on d4 we have h4
king the c5 we have h3 and now King to
b6 now forcing this trade so there's no
other option
captured we have eight captures unbe
seven bye neighbor and now h2 Network
brings the Queen enter game and so does
theory however it's two extra points for
white if it's one extra pawn then there
are there are often times where black
will hold the draw
however with two extra points it is it
is very difficult so Queen to e5 check
by neighbor and also neighbor has the
first move king f7 we have Queen to f4
again immediately offering a trade Queen
h6 check and now King c7 we have Queen
to g7 and now any check will be met with
moving the king and checking the White
King but now just Queen e5 again
offering a trade Queen g4g three and now
d4 starting to push the pawn with Queen
to b3 and now f5 just just pushing those
pawns with Queen to see four check Queen
to c5 blocking and now Queen to a for
but here Knepper just finds a Queen to
d5 check we have King to have 6 and now
Queen to see sex with check nicely
connecting here and it was in this
position that uh nigiri resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here
once you trade the Queen's and grab this
pawn it's just d5 and it's winning King
f6 these six you're going to get the
King f7 and that's just that the seven
king is seven King here and you are
grabbing a queen so yeah a game two went
to went to an opponent you who is now
leading the match and since we're not
gonna be showing any more games from the
match as both the game 3 and game for
ended in a draw nipple is is the winner
of the match however I will show the
position from game 3 which was very
promising for Geary although I just have
to switch sides there we go
so here is white here and this is the
position from game 3 so nipple has a
very nice special queen battery here
with a lot of pressure on g2 and the
knight is defending it so here nappa
basically forces a queen trade with E 5
saying if you move your night you're
getting checkmated so you have to trade
Queens and here there is a there is a
very tricky move instead of trading
Queens there is also Queen to b3 here
just with the threat of grabbing the
bishop and also the rook but after
Bishop to b5 defending both threats and
Knight captures Queen captures now you
get route
seven check kink the e6 and the now D
captures on e5 King captures on e5 rook
captures on h7 now creating a passed
pawn here and hereafter rook c1 check
King h2 and a queen trait for example
you would get this position will this
end game where a giri would be up upon
with a passport and h6 which is most
most likely winning but it's a it's a
whole lot to calculate so instead giri
decided to go for a different line which
is also excellent D captures on e5 first
F captures and now he traded Queens with
Bishop captures and now Knight to h3
going for Knight to g5 check which which
wins the h7 phone or even if the rook
moves even in the bishop so Bishop to d5
was played and now tonight's the g5
check by Gary King e7 and now Gary just
grabs that h7 for now creates a past H
pawn we've looked at g4 going after the
g2 pawn and now g3 and now when this
diagonal opened up now Knepper goes for
rook the c4 now threatening if you're if
you're not careful you're gonna get to
just the rook to c1 check fall by rock -
h1 checkmate
and here now URI had the opportunity but
he had to play f3 this just gives the DF
2 square for your King and there is
there's not too much Bishop captures and
a3 are just gonna move the knight attack
the bishop and after the bishop moves
you push h7 and now this is a passed
pawn on h7 rook rook will block at a3
and get the point out of the way now
you're gonna capture here you're gonna
capture here and you're just gonna win
the game in in the a
however gear we went for rook the b1
instead to defend the mate and this gave
an fo a free tempo would work the c8
we've looked at a 1 and now just rook
the h8 giving up the e5 pawn so rook
captures and then King to d6 and here
you have to give up the night rook the
g5 was played and now rook captures on
h7 rook captures and g6 with check King
e5 rook captures on a6 and here you have
this position where it's bishop against
four pawns so give it has four points
against nipples bishop but in the end
the game ended in it
so this was this was a good shot for
Geary to get back into the match but in
a Poe net for the magician he always
somehow does it it's incredible he can
just walk the edge and never fall it's
it's incredible but never wins the match
and these are the standings after the
three rounds that we've covered so there
you have it let me just let me just fix
this
yeah so Magnus Carlsen in first place
with eight points with seven points each
Cara Nakamura in second and with six
points ding Liron in third followed by
with five points Maxime Marshall gravy
on the pole machine Fabiano Caruana and
in last place so far without any points
on each giri and ali reza fallujah there
you have it a nice cross table from from
chess 24 website so those were the games
I do hope you enjoy them like I said I
hope you don't mind that I squeezed like
that
you're a very short game or maybe
opposition from the second game in this
video as but that's how I decided to do
it so I hope you enjoyed that as well I
would like to thank Marco Castro chief
Fabian with Frank Truslow Isetta rivers
and polar Hansen for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check too
on my previous video serum thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Magnus
Invitational and don't forget to join
the tournaments in the description below
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day